so
[Music]
so
[Music]
mic check mic check
easter sunday version what's going on
around
make sure my levels is good how are we
doing out here
how are we doing i see the chat piling
there see the lords piling in
what's going on good to see a couple of
y'all on a sunday man we know this is a
special edition
sad we won't talk xbox i don't know i
know but um
we we're holding that for a special
guest um addict's coming in i'm gonna
have to make sure he knows that he's
coming in hot
outta you live bro
if you're not ready to talk anyway
um yo what's going on jesse darby you
know what i'm saying
you're checking out fast okay okay adam
yeah i know he said we won't tell you
exactly we're holding the xbox stuff
we're holding iop for a very special
guest trust me
y'all gonna like it it's tuesday 5 p.m
eastern
you know i'm saying so this was
something king thought of he's like you
know what instead of not giving out
anything
you know i'm saying today let's give you
a little something little spoiler cast
whatever spider what up six player what
up 8k
w what's up it keezy best style fighters
yeah we're gonna talk about that
did that movie we're gonna talk about it
but look
sit tight the lords will be pulling up
like i said this will be a little short
little
edition just have some fun talk about
this thing and then again hold tight
because tuesday 5 p.m eastern we
definitely want to drop all of the
secrets and
and the fun and the guests and the
topics that y'all want to talk about so
that's what i got but i will be right
back and we will mic check and get that
thing going i'll talk to you in a minute
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
all right and we are
live special easter sunday edition
r r with the lords aka roundtable
reviews returns
special edition a little different on a
sunday man
keeping it casual keeping it light now i
know y'all like
where the iop at what's going on what's
this
but the reality is we have a special
guest that we might announce at the end
of the
end of the show and um we're just going
to do a shout out to king because this
was king's idea
he wanted to give the realm still
something because i would have went to
sleep i honestly love you guys
king king gets all the credit you know
there's a
14 guy he fought for y'all i was going
to sleep
but uh yeah man this is alright i was
back man we figured we'd do it back with
the pandemic obviously we solved
kai batsu shout out to matt's couple of
people used to do it with us when
things were normal right and we used to
be able to go to the theaters and stuff
but obviously things are different
but um forget all that you know y'all
know the rest of the laws is here addict
what's up man
he's in the bushes finding himself
eddie's beauty
he's talking to somebody he'll be going
off he's cursing somebody out he's
cursing somebody he curses don't you see
the hat on he said
don't you see i'm live
the hat is oh once the head is on i'm in
the booth yeah he bad you know
so what up man what's going on man
[Music]
yeah he's about to beat his brother
what's going on i was like listen i was
going to take a little trip this weekend
and it wound up not happening because i
my wife was like no we're supposed to
end we cannot be
enjoying ourselves this weekend we have
to be you know solid there so i'm like
okay i guess we're not going anywhere so
i was like okay so i guess we are going
to have a mini podcast on sunday she was
like
fine she rolled in the eye like yeah the
kid got me in trouble too because i told
the crew i'm like yo
i'm going now what up you don't say
covey night you know whatever whatever
at the spot a rooftop spot that's open
with social distinction
so i was like yeah i can't hang out late
like i thought
cause king wanted to be nice for the
realm and i'm like
this is gonna be a funny one because i
know i know there's
certain people on this panel that are
not fans of this type of movie
so yeah we're going to get into this
no doubt yes yes yes no doubt so i see
benjamin
he said attic brother getting the beats
yo he oh he turned the
a good stuff man i was telling old gig
and everybody i was like dad because
some said the same thing like i was i
thought i was gonna get [ __ ] to hang out
you know i said
what about you you had to work right
yeah i ended up working at 16. i'd still
be asleep but my brother
woke me up with like like cognito called
i'm like oh
i know let's get let's get this super
chat rook and we got michael
aka best size finest five dollar super
chat king
kong's chest hurts lml
we got to introduce the cake man king
what's going on casual r and r
you know what i'm saying what's going on
oh well it's a wonderful sunday
as i uh sip my uh
favorite drink
i see it's a holy day for most and you
know
for some it's not but we're trying to
give you some form of entertainment not
too long so it won't be three hours
today
uh but it's just something you know you
know because a lot of you guys
listen to us while y'all at work so
we're just gonna give you a little
something and i really wanted to talk
about this movie also
i want you guys to know that we're
trying to beef up the
the patreon content so we'll be doing
roundtable reviews at least once a month
to go directly inside the patreon uh for
the patreon people
and if to watch it live i think attic
has a formula
for them to watch it live and then we'll
put that behind
um the patreon for the patreon
subscribers to get a chance to check
that stuff out because
you guys do support and we want to give
back in return
so round table reviews let's see if
y'all like this let's see
keep in mind whatever happens on on the
patreon will be
done on the the members too because i
got to give my boy king
the achievement award today thank you
for doing this you know
this is him yo shout out to xbox man i
was able to pick this up this they
didn't give me this y'all i bought this
i'm not paid off
but yeah this is this kick this is
achievement forget it for getting us to
do extra content for the realm
you know what i'm saying so salute to
the king for this one thank you thank
you oh my god i didn't know
while i'm here i want to thank i want to
thank uh
the team i want to thank
the family that joined the realm i want
to thank all the patreons
i want to thank i want to thank all you
guys for putting this up
oh my god acceptance speech speech
whatever
cognitive force your hand oh i posted
we're going to announce the the guest on
twitter and when i do that it has to
happen it has to happen all right so we
but we do it at the end right
and keep in mind if anyone here hasn't
watched it and you don't want to stay
around for it for it
yeah i will spoil it yes
before we after this is over i will post
it on twitter before we actually
announce it
absolutely absolutely so look we'll get
right into it obviously you know what
i'm saying the let me
see yes please we have kadrian hardy aka
lost five
super chat king of all monsters all i
have to say
oh and then i'm sorry that's that's the
second one his first one was justified
which i thank you my brother much
appreciated it and that's kadeem hardy
yes
okay well it's spelled differently but
it's kidrian hardy how do you say his
name
kadeem
him
what's good my brother's addict is
hitting his brother with those old
school batman pound bang whoops
normally i am i i am uh being a little
too hard on them but
it wasn't today oh okay okay normally
you do normally do
so we caught themselves yes that's a
look reviews you gotta talk about it man
the big
match up monster film bash of the titans
you know what i'm saying
so um look how everybody assuming has
got a chance to watch including myself
very late but i want to go around the
room you know
around a table as far as you know just
our impressions now that we've watched
it how we feeling
it's open forum this is casual y'all so
whatever whoever would jump in and get
right to it
guys i watched it ten times okay okay
let's go with the ten times
i i've i
a suffrage achievement um
i'm i'm the dude in the rubber suit dude
they've been watching it for so long i
watched the old ones again
and i and i always compare it to
what it's directly linked to so my
impressions of it is
i'm blown away because when i got a
chance to watch the old touhou movies
and i and i watch them all the time
because i got monster week anytime i
want now i didn't have to wait till july
that's that's the only real time like i
was really happy for my birthday
because it always monster week always
fell on my birthday
in july and so now i don't have to i
could have monster week all the time i
got cake and ice cream ain't how i want
that's the perks of being an adult
so when i when i saw this i was like
i like the differences from godzilla and
godzilla king of the monsters okay
because those stories were more uh
actor-centric more uh character driven
for the characters outside of the
monsters
and the monsters to me was just like an
overarching
uh part to those movies right
like they were giant set pieces that
were used to push the uh the narrative
now uh in this movie the monsters are
the main attraction
and you know the characters are just
little set pieces to push the story
along
to get it to where they want it to be
like to get them to tokyo
right so uh normally you know everybody
thought they were might be uh fighting
in new york city i thought tokyo was the
best setting it was tokyo yeah it was
cool an old movie
so it should be tokyo now one thing i
did uh notice
i thought this movie was more um
more made for 3d with the high usage
of neon yeah the blues and the reds
so today uh because i haven't did it yet
but today i can force any movie into 3d
with my television
so i'm going to put on those powers yeah
i know this is 10k 20k
yeah king king yes it's not supposed to
look like it's not supposed to look like
that yeah
that crap but um what i'm doing because
i have to use a special battery that you
have to put in those glasses
so um i got the battery from um home
depot so i'm gonna put it in i'm gonna
watch it in 3d
alone today with nobody around with my
headset on um and then i'll let the
family partake with me later
i don't like to interrupt it but
i thought it i thought it it showed
like okay so the first godzilla movie
godzilla was really slow
yeah uh and lumbering the second
godzilla he was more nimble because he
had to fight king
dora and this movie
showed a uh crocodilian side
yeah a more savage
sinister petty side to godzilla
he was petty as hell in this movie and
kong showed a more bipedal
type of uh feel to it he was a more
nimble more calculating
he did things like he distract godzilla
by throwing the girder
to the floor and godzilla looked and
he's like dummy
his elbow he did two feet yeah he was
mad agile son with the joints
oh i was like damn it it was
lit like it was it was it was the fight
that we wanted to see the cgi
oh god the cgi was so on point
that you got a chance to see godzilla's
gills
yeah in his neck um that's my overall
impression of it we can go into details
in a second
but you know i'll hand it over because
i'm a little bit much
no doubt addict or something i'm going
to jump in and there's no initial
impressions now you've watched it
um as somebody who's again i'm like king
i
rub a suit all the way this is y'all
this is so young
because you remember there were times i
monster week when we were young right
they always had that monster week where
they showed them but they also
on channel 5 when they weren't showing
wrestling and when they weren't showing
the kung fu flicks they'd also show the
monster flick so that was
that was the other thing they would show
so
besides the cowboy movies which i didn't
like it yeah spaghetti
oh yes i'm not about that um
but so bringing it back to that i'm like
we
anybody who watched the original
godzilla versus kong no is that this
is you know there's a suspension of
disbelief about certain things
wait till it's my fault that said
i agree with king wholeheartedly that
this time the monitors
were the focus right where every in all
the other movies the tone was more
serious which i liked
but the fact that the tone was more
serious meant that
the actual human characters meant more
to the overarching story and the and the
monsters were this
kind of thing that they were trying to
control try to
either manipulate control whatever the
case may be it was different in this
because
in this they're like we need them to be
front and center
in order for this story to work now what
bothered me about this one is
i think they went too far into the
comedy where
the honestly the human characters didn't
matter
not at all and i don't mind your
100 you know handlebar mustache villain
i don't mind that necessarily
okay but because all the previous movies
didn't do that
and the fact that they took characters
from previous movies whose arcs were
previously
serious and made them into like comic
one-offs here yeah
i was like nah it doesn't fit like they
didn't find the middle ground they went
all the way left with it
and then to that end that part of the
story the whole conspiracy theory stuff
all that stuff
apex and that they went too far with
they were left that said the monster
mashing
yeah yo they did it they did it yo
i mean when it came to godzilla kong
that fight you got your money's worth no
lord addict i'm very curious about your
thoughts on this movie for some reason
i want to know what you think you seemed
excited when you told me about it and
you asked me if i was watching this so
like what was your initial impressions
godzilla versus kong to match up
well when i was growing up i didn't
really have this like monster we didn't
even know there's a thing to you guys
no i mean cog was dead he just it was a
real man
he didn't care about that i enjoyed it i
thought it was a great pace
movie obviously i thought stuff was
conditional and made no sense
godzilla his little time in the water
and they gave
kong his little time in the town because
he can move around cool a lot quicker
so like i guess they were trying to be
fair like okay we're gonna let
godzilla whoop hong kong here they like
because
it didn't really feel like it was it was
congress's godzilla it felt like it was
it was godzilla versus kong and the
humans yeah
thank you don't wait till it's my turn
wait till it's my turn you needed
somebody to tag in oh
no
first off i don't know why like it makes
no sense they're like
okay we can't move kong because
godzilla's gonna come all right how are
we gonna move
by the ocean the only way godzilla
travels
he caught him in traffic
i like how he was like yo we went
through these cedar blocks and he ain't
in these waters
where we like the fact that they knew
his hoods in the water
and you know later on they're like yeah
why don't we just fly them to where we
need to go
oh don't get me started you know what
was hilarious they're sitting there on
that ship
and so like and that little girl comes
by which i don't really ever explain how
like she just knows things that i had
the kong whisperer whoa maybe i missed
that like
but she was she's deaf so she
felt you know the the vibrations there's
a different vibration
so she's like oh buddy that different
when she goes up there she's like is she
sitting there shaking them she's like
what's wrong she's like
she's like she's poor i can't remember
it was so wack but she's sitting there
like looking outside
and then they're they're they're pretty
much like kentucky oh it's godzilla
and they act surprised like no because
they didn't see them on radar
[Laughter]
radar
is godzilla made out of like mythical
stone or something like
like how how was her radar just just
felling
water though she lit like that
and he's sitting there hitting with all
this stuff and he's doing damage to
godzilla
i'm like these predator missiles didn't
do [ __ ] to you
look godzilla had some of the greatest
plot armor known to man
[Music]
yeah godzilla is really impenetrable
like he's yeah
but kong kong got that leg though
he got that he got that axe
off the back of his yeah so get to see
what you did i'm gonna go too for my
friends because we got a lot of super
chats oh
let me see let me see i separated them
give me a second
uh went away dragons are two dollars if
attack kong showed his parkour skills he
was out
oh wow then we got best times finest
five dollar super chat this movie would
have been
been 30 minutes if the humans didn't
save kong numerous
thank you oh we go get it
dan lazaro with the five dollars it was
the dumbest movie i've probably ever
watched and the jokes were terrible at
too many humans godzilla one though it's
like you wanted something if i could hit
you order something you'll be on to
something right now
then we have dad the man cunningham with
the five dollar super chat
greetings i'll be loved the movie but
didn't like seeing mechagodzilla using
godzilla's face as a squeaky
queen yeah
kaiju fight at his best wide shots no
quick edits scaled the fight well
lit kong grew up not a baby anymore
godzilla was on his petty game after
beating ghidorah yeah after beating
ghidorah like he you know
he's he's out on another he was thugging
kaiju after that
there's a couple parts like i still
thought i still loved it okay so you
enjoyed it yeah yeah
but uh i i loved when when like godzilla
was getting that work work
from ain't no one could mess with me to
like come
please
you know how quick you know what's funny
when they grabbed
when when when godzilla done got
destroyed
and kong grabs his arm and godzilla it
was like
he awake
he was dead what's the thing like
you talk about like hong kong is
definitely like in terms of of
weaknesses he's
he's weaker than godzilla they did
detonate a nuclear bomb on his chest
like
yeah yeah yeah they're gonna get into
that that homie from uh true blood
that's that's the whole truth
how did you guys feel because i thought
this was epic but i did feel like it was
a little weird
like like godzilla got hit
with that um that acts at full strength
because they got charged remember uh
down in whatever the reverse world
whatever
yeah what is it the hollow the hollow so
the axe gets charged
and and and kong is giving godzilla to
work with his axe
but he's just like it's barely going in
a little bit
mecca he couldn't hold limbs off yeah
you know i don't really like how they
did that because i felt like they could
have did that a little better
because i felt like the moment that axe
was charged it was no longer
kong versus mega godzilla it was this
axe versus
mcguffin yeah in order to to to
push the plot point right i mean i
didn't mind it
i didn't find any of this because what i
really liked is
is like because godzilla realized when
he shot him that one time he he was
charging it
yeah he was defending himself so
godzilla's sitting there like
if i don't help this this this he said
i'm dead too
yeah if i don't help this gorilla dude
i'm screwed yeah and he's sitting there
and like he has it like this
and god says it's like i'ma charge that
it was great stuff get into a chat then
i'll go over this shoe no doubt we have
aerodynamics at the five dollar super
chat i need godzilla to have a rematch
of mechagodzilla at full strength
next up bring on ultraman and gamera
okay
okay then we have the homie
keep it up folks no doubt a little love
i appreciate
that much love thank you brother thank
you then we have
these masks i always say you're one of
the real oh he didn't realize it
absolutely thank you thank you so much
max the lazy otaku with the two dollar
super chat
as the man kanye once said what's the
king to a god
that's what i can't deal with today
that's what you came away with
everybody knows listen let me get it
you know look yeah king gone clown me
you know i'm definitely
casual cog in this mode like that stuff
growing up
never really appealed to me the monster
week stuff
and you know i just never got to it but
um
as king would have me watch this movie
yeah all right so i started getting into
it and look it's overall
you know it's it's a fun movie it's it's
what it is it is it is what it is
here's my thing as the casual observer
like to me i'm like okay this is
supposed to be the heavyweight matchup
we're about to see what's going on
and like from the start of the film you
know i mean i'm like
you know he's like calm he's like
in like subjugation like from from jump
like so i'm like okay
he's not roaming around okay fine then
like attic said they bring him via bull
in
shackles so this man is like to me it's
like i the impression you know
since you brought that up yes like when
home girl's like you gotta release kong
he's got to defend himself
i'm like i don't know why this dude's
even restrained at this point
it's the moment you heard the moment you
hear godzilla yeah let's let's release
this
there you go it was just like i'm
sitting there and i'm trying to
un like i'm trying to get into the
mythos of kong i'm trying to
you know and it's like sit he's like
literally
in slavery from the minute i see him
right so i'm like all right i'm trying
to understand okay plot okay
and the bulk part is when i kind of roll
my eyes a little bit because all right i
do like the fact
that they showed his intelligence like
the sign language with the girl thought
i thought that was a nice cue i thought
that was cool
so now godzilla show up kind of for the
first time for the match-up right
this the water scene the water let's get
it so all right they gotta release him
okay they released it right
to me it was an automatic l when
godzilla had him in the dope fiend
and pulled him under the that's what i
was
water
that it was godzilla versus kong versus
hugo i was like
the move hold okay if the humans
wouldn't shot those missiles
in the first it
[Applause]
knew he was sitting there like like when
he got in the water with him and he
tried the first time and he got up a
little bit
and he got up at the top kong knew he
was like
the moment he tried to grab me he's like
this dude about to kill me like someone
gotta help me you're like yeah
and it's like okay i just want to say
all the godzilla movies we always
thought godzilla held his breath and he
came out of water
right right this movie show they
literally
showed the gills when he was coming
up so you're like oh yeah he can play
that stuff
mm-hmm so i didn't like that part but no
i mean it was just for me
it was like i'm i'm looking at the
headline and i'm like
this movie should have been over already
like he took the l already the humans
had to come and throw a depth charger
but they didn't put that
but that's not his element all right i'm
gonna go there right you're right solved
you're right
so i at first i was mad i'm like he
whacked like he got already body but
but in his defense i mean okay well they
setting it up this is not his element
you know what i'm saying in the water
whatever whatever yeah he was
like the moment i saw them transporting
him like i knew
they kind of ruined that part because in
the movie you saw godzilla was was
uh what was was in the water and they
came face to face
so like the moment i saw that i was like
yeah they they're about to fight
they saw the show in the trailer and i
like i already knew it was out
right so i'm already i was like he's
definitely not doing no i'm not doing
nothing and then i took it to sausage i
chilled i said wait
water element that's godzilla whatever
so now
fast forward right now we in the city
you know what i'm saying we're getting
it in
you know what i'm saying okay here we go
here we go let's go and
he is getting roughed up badly and no
no no he actually took that win he
he was getting he's mixing it up no he
actually took
i don't know okay the
did he technically get that win that
particular yeah he did because
yes but he spent like like he got burnt
he got
beat up like that's fine i mean that's
the type of w he's gonna get
so he's not gonna get it out and now w
so tell me why you consider that the w
okay okay even even even eric northman
said you know i'm gonna keep calling
eric
the true blood i know him from true love
yeah i love him
but um even he said okay i guess round
two goes to khan
right remember yeah and then godzilla
got up
and then godzilla said oh he's a
different type of kaiju
the gloves is off and he fighting the
rag dogs
and to me the ultimate when he had the
foot on the chest
that that is you're going to submit
you'll go bend the knee
to me i was like oh that's
he said you're going to submit and i'm
going to walk away and turn my back
to you like i think at that point
godzilla's never fought anyone that like
this i mean he he had to
like do the nuclear thing to kill the
three-headed thing i don't remember what
that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
king wasn't from this planet right well
you but you get what
he never fought someone like on equal
ground that one
obviously godzilla had an advantage
right in that environment
was able to maneuver because godzilla
can't do the stuff to calm yeah
right well yeah so it kind of like
equaled it out a little bit and godzilla
respected him
because they went on equal terms and he
he was able to do a little damage like
godzilla was kind of shocked he's like
oh
like it's like okay break it break down
in the middle break down the mythos all
right this is the mythos
right there's always one king above
the the kaiju okay now during their
battles
between uh the kong species and godzilla
species
it's always been a hierarchy one would
lead
and the other one would be under right
so um
so that's what that dynamic is right
that's what the
lineage is but between the other kaijus
that's up from this planet
you know it's uh order it's always a
leader subordinate type of thing
right not to kill them right not what
they did
right but king ghidorah wasn't from this
planet
got you and he was trying to impose
because that's a that's an external
threat right you know like so when you
fight with the homies you fight with the
homeless man it's like i'm not trying to
get it
i got dressed but to me
i agree so the way i visualize it with
the foot on the chest was you bend the
knee
and he yelled it reminds me of spartacus
remember when spartacus was losing to
richard he had to throw the fingers up
that's what that was to me please yeah
so you could live to another day
what i liked about it because let's be
real here like
is a phenomenal you know beast for
monster
whatever you guys like to call these
things um
okay he's a great hiju but
like even from like a standpoint like he
doesn't have the tools he can't fight
long range really without
right like throwing the only weapon he
has it's like
so many tools he got like like i think
we all
knew going into this that godzilla was
going to win them like
i think we all even people that was
voting kong was like
it's like they were they all weren't
voting kong because they thought he was
going there
because he was the underdog there's one
there's only one that's been called king
of the mosque he's
been called king of the monsters for
years
so i mean i i again i'm never the dude
that's just gonna go for the the dude
that's been slotted in the top slide i'm
gonna do that so i'm gonna i'm gonna be
a kong dude
okay oh you're a car dude i'm gonna
let's get some of these super chats
before we yeah we gotta get a super chat
we gotta get this we about to get deep
yeah
we got five dollars super chat king you
right godzilla was so petty after the
fight was over he turned his back on
kong yelled at him and said you don't
want it
i slipped off yo you're stupid he said
he looked at him and said you're
pardoning my back
you remember that look at that you're
called my back
it wasn't even like that too man like
him he looked at kong and kong was like
and godzilla's like you best drop that
axe
just like it was like godzilla was like
saying
you better don't get all all extra on me
because you killed mecca godzilla he's
like i still give you that work
yeah but it wasn't respecting it we'll
get to that there was a respect
but it was it was one of those like i
don't think either one of them wanted to
do it again
again i agree i don't think i didn't see
that as respect
i i really saw that as kong like this
through going with my ass again
he was like really i just helped i just
helped you yeah
he had that it was like a little bit of
worry a little concern like we're gonna
do this
it looked like man when he dropped that
axe and godzilla weren't right instead
of straight
yeah i think kong was like oh i dropped
the ball
good to see you
geek with the three dollar super chat
what's a god to a non-believer
let me get for it take ten dollars in
chat the only titan that could beat
godzilla is mechagodzilla kong is a
washed up old gorilla
that's past his prime that's why the god
put his foot on kong chest
human save kong twice he he lied they
saved khan
three times at the end of the day
regardless what was saved i was saved
like
i still like the movie because kong like
at the end of the day kong doesn't have
long range mecha beams that just melt
through everything
and like he he used what he had and he
used it very officially very well
but i listen people people talking real
wow right now
people tend to forget in the original
godzilla reboot
the mutos were given godzilla that
worked
and and until and until one of the
mudo's uh
baby babies were being destroyed and got
distracted that's when godzilla was able
to run up behind him and put him in the
dope
that the people don't remember that they
forget the details
they don't remember king ghidorah giving
godzilla at work
actually okay so oh king don't like that
no but it was it was true there's a plot
point for the movie but
okay okay okay they always gotta jump on
my voice
so oh wait so it's like the old kung fu
flicks with the with the old boss where
they got to jump
jump my man master ball you know how
that gold had to drink the white
like i can't i can't say i can't give
like godzilla all this plot armor
and then like i mean everyone else saw
this plot arm and i get godzilla like
god like kong literally hit this man
with this this this beast with an axe
fully charged
in the movies like you can't cut his leg
off that's that's not cool
you can damage him a little bit with a
me first roll let me talk about king
ghidorah yes godzilla had king ghidorah
beat before the humans interfered
well actually oxygen
uh nuked down in the water and and and
killed him and left kingdom king one
second someone put a good
point in the chat they said kong sat on
an island for 30 years scratching his
his arse with wow godzilla saved the
world
so like i think that that is that that
is fair criticism like god
he ain't been in the gym was actually
like fighting oh you got to get you got
to get uh when you when you get to that
super chat yeah we got massive profazi
yeah it's one specific one i gotta
answer because
that's a retcon cause fozzie but i'm
gonna get to that okay
so super chat do you want to answer now
or what you wanna do
let me see uh we gotta oh wait but
you're one point the one point before we
get there yeah at one point with king
adora
if they don't interfere with them when
he got king ghidorah in the water and he
ripped that head off
fight over any time you get in the water
with guys
it didn't happen on film so it didn't
happen you know
look i gotta disagree with you king
because
uh we've seen that every time
uh godzilla gets someone in the water
some humans come in
what they do to save him humanoid comes
in with their own bs
get to get the totally played game so
get the total oh we got uh tony play
game two dollar super chat kong was a
double
a he didn't want to fight slavery it
looked bad when he was on the boat
yeah you got one two like one nonsense i
gotta shout out to homie barry what's
the king to the god teams
no no he didn't switch but you just want
to wait twelve hours of a chat oh shout
out to the human
to ship the [ __ ] defibrillator
yes
to fight destroyer this is the fight i
want to see who is destroyed who's the
strongest
he's a world beater he actually kills
godzilla oh
the destroyer that's how they oh oh look
at that look at
the car call it's like that's the movie
no i want i want to see that because
kong did not live up to i'm sorry song
your man was i was very disgusted i was
but
this is the this is the problem we're
not watching kong skull island
yeah right you got to watch it i had to
watch his journey today
well he only has that one movie
specifically him
but when you have when you have samuel
jackson could take you out
samuel jackson got the business yeah but
no but samuel jackson
if if there's no help again samuel
jackson takes
two never ended zillow was playing
rope-a-dope
concord elves the whole field no
cotton got round two man that's so
that's what i was saying man like i
don't consider like
technically i guess that was round two
because a human ironically said he won
round two
but like if we ain't gonna act like like
two minutes later
like kong was dead what yeah
get get get off there we have uh fozzie
oh five dollars for jack kong is still
young also you remember slick throwback
they defcon
remember electricity soups of kong like
nuke soup
okay so that's not true all right before
in the old movie they had to give him
something it would they had to give him
a guffin
to put him on equine equal playing field
with uh godzilla
so in the old movie he would buy
electrical lines
and charge up and grab godzilla and
shock him
so that's probably that video game
rampage yeah it was it was like that it
was like that
so what they did was they retconned that
because that was
nonsensical so they had to give a
different plot point and give you a
different mcguffin the mcguffin that he
got was his ancestral axe
his ancestral axe was made from the the
um
the dorsal fins of dead godzilla's now
when he's sitting on that throne
and you see all those axes that get
around
that was the whole lineage of every
fight and how many godzilla's that live
instead of one godzilla remember i told
y'all before how i thought the movie was
going to go
godzilla was able to resurrect himself
they took that away
what they're saying is that godzilla's
don't resurrect themselves it's a race
of godzilla's
living a hollow earth and and travel
that way we saw
godzilla's world uh where he lived it
was more egyptian like
yeah worship by his people on his side
this when you saw kong's um
right side he was worshiped by and they
and they figured that there was hominids
that was there
but they didn't see any at that point in
time because
they would get to that point later but
when he sat on his throne
he was king of his castle that was his
castle
and when you godzilla went to go die in
the king of the monsters
that was where godzilla uh goes to
recharge his energies
you saw both home worlds both home you
know they
technically their houses yeah and um
that's that's
that's the plot point there all right so
when they were talking about the the
the energy those dorsal fins and i think
it's it's kind of weird because they
charge up whenever one godzilla charges
his
his uh his dorsal fin up to shoot his
energy beam
they all charge up okay you don't
understand so i think you know
when one is about to fight the whole
family can get charged up at the same
time
it was just a nice plot point to see
they took away old tropes and gave you
new stuff too yeah yeah
because if you remember i think was it
was it in king of the monsters when he
was when godzilla was badly damaged like
he doesn't
resurrect but he can recharge like
he's close to death and you remember
like like i said
if you see these it gives more context
they had to go
down to where godzilla lives which they
had never found before right and he was
there recovering
they needed him to come back to fight
the door and they went and they they
basically ken watanabe
went and and he sacrificed himself right
he set off a new
oh i saw a little clip yeah i saw i know
you're talking about okay wasn't that
wasn't that his son
that was put on the mech godzilla yeah
okay okay i did
i did see a snippet of that scene of an
old scene with the father with the noob
in front of okay okay
because he believed in god's election
right godzilla was here as a believer
uh entity got you so he sacrificed
himself for the greater good
all right so let me ask one question
before we go ahead
like so again because you got to educate
casual call so the thing is
this new mythos where they're trying to
say like this this
generational ancestral fight right right
and this is kind of a reoccurring thing
and then one
kills the other and then it's the next
generation like that's he's doing with
this doing
basically yeah okay they're both alphas
of their own races right
and that's always been like that i think
the fight through time immemorial is
one of them versus the uh guys versus
mccoys
okay we have let me see let me see
michael
dick we got yeah so young remember yeah
michael hey best i find this five dollar
super chat people forget that guys it'll
literally
literally one was at the temperature of
the sun when he was evaporating kick
ghidorah also took a nuke to the face
and got up
yes that is true he's born from nuclear
he's born from nuclear radiation
don't forget that he's he was supposed
to be uh humanity's consequence they
just turned it around to me
they turned it around like uh no
no jokes here if you ever get the chance
to watch the original godzilla
original guy that's like a horror movie
and
it speaks about like the the the horrors
and the
heroes of hiroshima exactly and what
what could come of it
that's why his skin looks like that
because they wanted to depict
the the portrayal of how the
victims of hiroshima would be yeah you
know like
like i'm not i'm not i'm not complete
like adverse on the
on the lord oh you don't know the law
yeah i don't know so like
originally originally he he was born
from like radiation from hiroshima yeah
from the nuclear he's
he's the consequence of nuclear fall
that's that's what they wanted to do
because without being too political that
would teach a lesson about because the
movie
was wouldn't have been uh seen
so what they had to do they had to make
uh because they wanted to bring
awareness to it right
right but they had to make a monster to
give
the level of fear that's what uh um is
right
he had to make godzilla a terrifying
horror film
and it's a it's a horror film it's a
horror movie straight up wow
that's what
i was just going to say man like at the
end of the day there was a lot of plot
armors going on here you know we pointed
them all out but
i i think you know we knew that was
going to happen yeah we knew that
godzilla like if they if they if the
fight would have went
how the fight would have went uh he
would have died in like 10 seconds
exactly
i looked at him i was like this dude
got destroyed in the water rifle
rightfully so that was the funniest part
when he took him underneath
and then second off like i love this one
kong they needed to spawn the the the
axe out of nowhere
he had to go to another dimension pretty
much to get that
even to even be on on ground turns of
call
and when he actually hit godzilla with
the axe
it's it's like as they looked at me like
oh that was a lot of wasting time you
did wasn't it like
the acts didn't help you did
one guy hits me in the dm and says well
kong hit him square in the face he
should have split his forehead
technically the blast was ending when he
hit him and it really hit the blast so
he gave the last blast and and it was
just like a concussive force
that knocked godzilla down and that's
how kong won that round
anytime your back hit the floor and you
out cold you're done son
i mean as much as i don't want to admit
give it
up you give it up i got round two give
it up
godzilla hit him in his shoulder though
was petty when he hit him
when he shot the beam and caught kong
and the shoulder comes
is
the giant plot hole uh plot armors that
you know
that both got both right i honestly feel
like
if they if they didn't want to put
godzilla in any other game
or any other movies or anything like
that that acts what a deacon like would
have been like
yeah it's straight up lizard he could
grow it back
here's my question i know this your man
but it's like
how they got your man in a jurassic park
lockdown
situation like how is he even in that
situation where he's
servitude in a fake simulated world
that's what pissed me off from the start
i didn't like the fact that they were
holding they were they were holding him
with this white glove
that you know if godzilla sent us him is
a wrap for him and i'm just like
i'm like damn like and then think about
it is so all right you're protecting him
on the one hand
yeah then you go and you expose him in
the worst way
because because you
then you transport him in the worst way
possible
so do you think that like in the battle
of monsters whatever that movie was
called do you think
it would have been cool if like kong
randomly showed up there like
oh no no see okay so you talking about
the last movie
they had all the monster that was there
right and you saw all the kaiju being
woken up
right that wasn't the main attraction
well i i get that but i'm saying from
like a perspective like
like because kong's really like the
human one like he's the yeah
that's why they wanted to be all nice
with him and i get that but like to me i
feel like
the humans about to get this work like
they were godzilla want to say that the
humans would have got that word
but to me they would have let kong go
wild in that movie
and the fact that they didn't is kind of
a plot armor in itself because
yeah but i think in that in that movie
they needed to
build godzilla up again like it's called
godzilla king of the monsters
right right right so they needed to
build him up as this solitary like five
times you know what's crazy
five times can they put cog in their
stupidest
position i'm gonna keep it a bug though
he would be so good is that crazy he
wouldn't dora's an
alien that's how he had it which one's a
three-headed oh okay okay you never saw
that movie dude
i don't know about this i'm here for
that for that show check this
check the last one all right so so first
of all i'm gonna give a shout out to hbo
max
okay right this movie was released in
the movie theaters
and the fact that you signed up for max
you're able to see this
shout out to all the streaming services
that are doing this
uh you know type of thing during this
pandemic time right
so you was able to watch it at the
comfort of your home 17 million
new subscribers happened that day you
know for the zack snyder cut
and now we don't know how many people
are tuned in for godzilla versus
kong new subscribers i think it's
thriving it's a fantastic service
the thing is overseas it's still sold
over 130 minutes
wow yes wow i didn't know that yeah yeah
this is
it's a smash hit it really killed it
and i'm glad i'm just showing that other
countries is starting not to take this
oh get the super chat because there's
somebody somebody said something too
that i got i agree with i will
please give you a chance please we gotta
get all this from jack okay all right
all right we go okay let's just before
we before we get there all right
all right we're gonna talk about the the
the three times that kong
was saved right let's go
give me one second before we got going
there was said in
in the chat he said kong actively
ignored i'm not even trying to butcher
that thing's name
his alpha call i'm assuming that was
like the the boss from
the last movie remember he was he was
protected he's
very far away thank you they gave you
the answer for why
kong didn't show up in that fight but
wasn't there monsters all around the
world in the last right
so i've reached them all but kong okay
but kong was already captured by monarch
which we didn't know
that monarch already had uh went to
skull island
they already beats breech they're
impenetrable exactly which is why they
had to create that impenetrable
that was that dome joint so they were
already
there to protect calm right because kong
was really the smallest one out of all
of them
remember when the guy comes up and he
says oh he's grown too large over time
right i don't think that this
environment is sustainable
right i remember the guys think about
our offshore um
viability off-site viability and she
said godzilla was sent some and who's
that
in the chat mm-hmm the spamming somebody
spamming
somebody yeah they got the mods got it
the mom's got it okay that um
get them out of here um yeah so you know
that offsite viability
and she said that you know godzilla
would send something and it would be a
damn sentence now
godzilla is over three uh 300
you know feet tall some 300 000 feet or
something like that
and kong is only 180. when we first
saw him he was only 80 foot tall right
you know so over time he grew that extra
100 feet so
let me ask you a question then king do
you think that
kong should have had another movie
before this they couldn't
they couldn't stretch it yeah that would
have been a big stretch because again it
would have been
kong has to leave the island
for godzilla really that's there's no
reason for him to leave
skull island otherwise i get that but
it's just like they go from being like
it's like i feel like first off khan
didn't even really
it felt like kong didn't really have any
experience fighting godzilla and that
automatically put him at at the low end
like yeah but yeah
skull crawlers oh my god like i feel
like he should have had another movie in
some way yeah
if you think about it though like
classically like
the only rogue in kong's rogues gallery
is godzilla whereas godzilla's rogues
gallery is all these other monsters all
the bosses and stuff yeah i got you
i got you we got to get these super chat
let's kick it let's go let's get to
these super chats
oh yeah
remember at the beginning they was
fighting the whole time opening credits
showed that godzilla and kong
were beating other kaiju but it wasn't
them
so what's next for this monster universe
because now king kong
and my god godzilla cool i don't know
about cool
he's a subordinate
i can't even i can't even try it
is it show like look like king
kong doesn't have to hide from godzilla
anymore like godzilla
gave you that work he's complaining
you've established
and he threw up the the capital of the
drake
he's compliant it was like one of those
things i mean i already gave you that
work
oh my god no but the thing is
if they ever if they that kong is never
going to bow to him though like he
making his ass whip
but he's going to keep fighting the
bully like you know we
just because
all right solve first off if kong
was about that life and he ain't bound
to know what the moment he pulled up on
him
he would he would have died at the end
of this movie
but the thing is you know we call it
when you open up when you were you all
the way
they got you like this and you opened up
and it got
looking over you like what and he dig
the foot
in them right under the rope that's what
it was
like wow
godzilla's sitting there talking uh like
it's like yeah he ain't doing nothing
he started go going towards the water
kong's like yeah just leave
please don't play he said he looked
relieved he never leaves
all right so that that we still got
super chats
we still got super chat we keep
interrupting to the old movie
but that step on the chest it was
significant because
anybody that saw godzilla king of the
monsters no
godzilla can crush your chest right
right so when he stepped on the chest
the first time kong was like
get that foot off
the sign language girl said his heart is
slowing yeah
all right so if you watch king kong i
mean godzilla uh king of the monsters
when he stepped on the door his chest
because no mercy you out of here
yeah and he killed him that's how okay
so you said it's like a respect
yeah so it no it was you just gonna bend
the knee you know i'm i'm
i'm the boss here you are working
you're working so i'm trying to act like
you pushing waiting
for your workers
what's next for the monster universe
what do you think is going to happen
next if they don't
i don't know nothing about the monsters
well being there for all i know they can
start playing checkers after this i
don't know
we gotta they didn't have any uh
extra scenes at the end i believe that
they're going to
fix it let's let's get the rest of super
uh jay barry
all right yo bad people it's a couple i
want to answer we got best stuff
that makes sense yeah i i'll give them
borrowers
which is true which is true they keep
them separate oh let me see we have a
murray
bestseller is fine as far as super chat
godzilla voices if he dies he died
back the ivan drake let me get
the monster in hollow earth almost
killed kong because remember when they
did a little snake put the thing
and put the mask over his face got you
again
oh god i just got it
this whole time but kong was put in that
situation because he was saving yeah
this is another thing like he keep
putting this man in dangerous situations
[Laughter]
that monster put the thing over his face
we have positive five dollars through
chad the storm took over the island it
killed everything except kong and the
little girl come protecting yeah that's
why the little girl
is the kong whisperer um then we got the
dj birdo five dollar super chat
y'all done did it now i
i'm the one who said roundtable reviews
oh my bad so i'll get the cheese y'all
so i'll get it
we gotta get chicken but i'm the one
that pushed sunday that's all yeah
you're the one that voiced the show
today
yeah that's the only reason why you know
um that's beautiful though
that's the only reason why you know um
we pushed it i just pushed it for today
we could have did this
exactly there we go and we did that on
the symbols uh
channel yeah yeah so if y'all want to
see another round table review we did
one with
um you know i think you really need to
go watch that yeah
i was good what we did was it was
assembled was lit a symbol was lit
and mortal kombat is going to be oh yeah
it's going to be it's feelings and more
we got to do we're doing our falcon and
winter shoulder stuff and we wait until
after the whole thing
i'm not caught up okay okay
and for the most part like we probably
will keep this just us for we won't
really have guests for these things yeah
no guess who's keeping us yeah let's
keep it let's keep talking
this is oh
no i just wrote that okay okay i've done
it now okay
there's a reason kong was shown swinging
hollow earth he bowed here
for this video shout out to playstation
i was on a podcast
oh yesterday yo they got a great punch
so they got a great playstation player
and you know
i i listen to that and i want to just
say something real quick about like
jabari our chat like i know that you
feel like because you the playstation
dude like that
that you gotta like beware you on what
chat you speaking
stuff but like our chat is it go to
block you because you have a bid
look first of all man
listen right now y'all in a position
where we godzilla and y'all calling we
don't
uh shout out to that definitely go watch
that but um he said that you know he'd
be in the chat he'd be scared to talk
sometimes
it's like dude like like if anyone gives
if anyone
injustively like mutes you or something
like that just hit me up like you could
talk no
sorry the whole man pull up and you're a
mod so you can't really be touched
he's not he's not disrespectful yeah
this is this is what i like about
everybody here regardless to what i mean
i sometimes i see other people chat and
i just don't
i'm just like wow y'all just wild out
there but over here you guys are really
respectful
and you know there's no cursing at each
other and stuff like that and no no you
know
remark but this ain't about that this is
not about video games yeah this is about
you know the one-on-one well
so the question i got for y'all is um
you know from what y'all explaining
you know obviously this is more built up
for the match-up and and the monsters
took more the stage which i i'm feeling
all of y'all kind of felt
good about this so i would call talk
about the human side you just say it for
a bit
and um you know the plot points there
like how was y'all feeling it about that
and like
was it that homegirl from um stranger
things was in that too or
something yeah bobby brown yeah i feel
like her i feel like her whole daughter
her name is millie bobby brown like she
could
the water and the thing like they could
have been out of this movie and it would
have been
this is what bothered me because her
character right her character she's the
daughter
of two researchers who in in king of the
monsters they were introduced
where and they were introduced with a
backstory that didn't happen in the uh
the previous movie so basically
they lost their son during the original
godzilla movie the 2016-2014 one right
so after that they became part of that
that that shadow sort of organization
monarch to try to sort of uh follow
godzilla and and sort of study him or
whatever the case may be
right so she lost her brother in that
and
and in in the other movies like her
parents have
significant sort of roles in what
happens with godzilla and
the return of the other of titans and
all that stuff so
it's like her role was more serious and
they turned her into a joke in this
movie
in a way that i i said they went too far
with it they went too far with it for me
conspiracy theory thing
yeah the dude with the podcast yeah
because the thing is i felt like they
introduced him and they're like oh i
lost my wife and this that and the other
and it that is all
thrown under the rug that's that doesn't
mean he kind of annoyed me i'm i ain't
going to
you know what's crazy they they put
what i really wasn't feeling people is
he had that
like he is like the biggest thing that i
was really annoyed with is he had that
that flask that had the the the alcohol
that his wife gave him
and they made that like such a a
memorable thing man this dude's about to
like drink this because he thinks he's
about to die
and they're just gonna let the fat kid
but he took it
over
hey i'm yeah like you're gonna just like
like i wasn't feeling that i was like
like there was a hundred different ways
you could have done without taking my
man's alcohol
take his alcohol don't let him get
whisked up on the job
we out here trying to find solutions you
trying to get wasted
delilah she said i guess i missed the
spoiler cast delilah in the title it's
in the title
uh delilah we got to get you we got a
fraud alert
yeah hold on hold on anybody in here
talking about oh they telling the movie
they know what you know what you you
got the new achievement i do i do feel
like shout out to the lion that's the
whole way i do feel like because
the obviously they kept calling alive
because what my original
worry about this was is they were going
to introduce
uh mechagodzilla like in the middle of
their fight
and they wouldn't finish their fight you
know what i'm saying like he had to come
that's what i enjoy i enjoyed that they
actually showed like a winner
like godzilla godzilla dumb made him
submit
because you know he was sitting there
like having that i ain't doing this
and then godzilla put his uh his foot on
his chest and kong's like yeah
i think i'm gonna die now
i really enjoyed that they they had a
conclusion to their fight before they
brought before the year i didn't like
that okay
well all right first let's give the
director
respect because he said he did a really
good job yeah everybody regardless of
the picks we interrupt your ips is high
attic let him talk the director said
that there it will
be uh uh a concise winner there will be
a winner
there won't be any ambiguit uh ambiguity
sovereign ambiguity thank you to
to thank you ambiguity i have a problem
with that one you're good
but there won't be any vagueness in
the the winner because in the first
touhou movie they had two shots
they had one for the um asian market and
one for the american market
where the godzilla swam away because
they fought underwater they went
underwater and fought and
godzilla swam away and the asian market
won and king kong swam away
in the american market one so there was
no concise winner
he said no there will be one king
at the end of this and you know we got
godzilla
as the the pure clean-cut victor
and of course we're gonna give a lot of
uh concessions to kong
right kong wasn't as versed at godzilla
in fighting
you know kang for only the skull
crawlers that wiped out his whole family
so as a child he's been terrorized
by this one kind of kaiju and then
excuse me
the next kaiju he does me in in in the
um
the inner wharf the hollow earth is uh
he wins one fight and then he gets
wrapped up
like a mummy it almost dies
so so the next time he does see the next
kaiju which is godzilla
he's like okay let's go i'm gonna pull
that all out i'm gonna give all his work
and he goes in and gives the work and he
gets worked as well
um i thought that was the most vicious
godzilla i've ever seen
any movie because he got dirty with him
yeah yeah cause
it was a point where kong did the paul
call and he gave him a [ __ ] off
and he's doing that and he's giving him
the people elbow he's he's actually
throwing them to the ropes and he's
coming back and giving him
the arm slide i'm like yo kong is crazy
he's doing
crazy moves and then godzilla said all
right
i'm gonna beat you something terrible uh
he threw his arm he caught his arm
ripped it out of socket
and dragged him with the socket
all over the floor kong is trying to get
away kicking his
like no please kind of he grabbed him by
his foot it starts to mangle
and that's a nice winner
he killed kong because if that ship does
not land on
facts but if true blood didn't show up
with the defibrillator
it was a wrap
i did like how they gave like kong a
little redemption and let him be the one
yeah that was the redemption i did
because like like i i assume
you know any type of mecca is like the
one that always beats the original
like yeah i don't know godzilla but i'm
assuming that godzilla always gives
godzilla the word
yo so we go we're going to talk about
when godzilla got punched in the face by
mechagodzilla yeah
what did y'all think about the straight
rip
pacific rim rip-off where they use the
mind of king ghidorah
oh okay pilot first first mega godzilla
first let's say this
you know that's one universe right this
pacific rim universe
is this same universe really is it yes
okay confirmed no this is that this is
the same this is the same so
the the kaijus they fight in that that's
in the future okay
oh so so in their future godzilla and
king kong and all of them
lost and now they've broken they took
over the world by this time
you know would be crazy if they didn't
die and they do like a like
a crossover like a pacific river yeah i
like that those are those are the
titanfall dudes right they got the
titanic
the ones you have what was the thing
with the kaiju where they
they they come out of this black hole or
something like that but they're coming
from another dimension
right there you go right they come from
the hollow earth no
it was like the same thing no no no it's
so when you go into their that that
portal where they're coming from coming
from another dimension and they go
into the pacific rim if you watch
pacific rim 2 they go in and they
detonate the new because they was trying
to send them all
over at that time um so
but this is the same universe you know
that's why they call them um mutos
because uh or kaiju's you know uh
noodles is the other kaiju they call it
kaijus
for that aspect to keep the lineage
going through
right so this is earlier on that's
future technique fired mike said i think
king got that
information
so the the the
that guy king the um
the the tech that you've seen here that
they're gonna bridge later because he
wasn't strong enough they needed two
people
in order to control a mech of that size
okay right so that's where that whole
pacific that's their mythos
that wouldn't make sense and it's kind
of weird that they went that direction
they might be doing a crossover in the
future
yeah so that that might be the thing
okay but
mecca all right so mechagodzilla
i'm glad they didn't do old school oh
slow mechagodzilla i just got rockets
and that's yeah
he had to be a super threat in the form
that he can challenge two alphas and
he can beat them individually kill them
off right he was designed to kill
godzilla
he could have killed the both yeah oh
i'm going to have that axe
if if it wasn't for them they shut down
the power thing or something too but
that'll continue
yeah so um when he punched godzilla in
the face
because it's the first thing godzilla
came on you know guys are like yeah
what's up cause he
he busts out the building said yo hold
on
[Laughter]
we just came out of the building like
yeah yeah radio's out here fighting
oh okay he's gonna get straight to it
yeah he made him more agile they made
him more robotic in the sense that he
can do different things because he is
a robot he shot the rockets at him but
when he
charged his arm up and gave him a
thunder punch to the mouth yes
and godzilla fell back like oh how many
people in here got punched in the face
so hard that they saw spots on the floor
realized
oh i'm in a fight fight over a fight
fight
type of fight and i said when he got hit
i said it take me back to when i got
punched in the face
and i was like oh he got hit like that
did you think you're the man until you
get hit in the face
in these super chats man i'm learning
more for these super chats i've learned
so much
i'm learning so much so let's listen
let's get to this all right so we got
guys
yeah bestseller's finest um five dollars
super chat i'm a godzilla fan but let's
be clear mecha godzilla was on a whole
other level on god and then this dude
was a ufc fighter respect mechagodzilla
yeah
he was agile they couldn't yeah if they
weren't the other rally it would not
have been a good look
then we have uh cheryl walker with the
five dollars chad i want to thank phil
spencer for convincing wb to put that
concert day in day like game fast
y'all messi y'all what that game told me
yeah i really do watch
that game
jack king can we say this is a king
ghidorah rematch in some way because
they were using king ghidorah as a mind
to power the mecca godzilla
no yeah no i don't know it's a whole
different gender
fly i mean yeah so he comment coming
then all right
he did he did it there we go and we have
dan lazzaro five dollars super chat when
kong's arm was dislocated he pulled the
rig some lethal weapon to fix his limp
arm
that was awesome he do it yeah
i'm back in the game baby mari there we
go
murray five dollar super chat pacific
rim dimension is where king ghidorah
comes from
okay but uh is it or they said he's an
alien from out of space he's an alien
from outer space
and you know um but it's hard to tell
like they can do it that easy though
yeah they could
they could act like that's a dimension
to the the place where they're from and
they're
and they're from another place on the on
the universe
yeah they're
they have not explained the whole
universe connection so congress godzilla
was the setup yeah
it was weird that it didn't have if it's
a setup that they didn't have some sort
of post credit scene or anything like
that there was nothing that really
leads into something else had a lot to
do with it yeah and that's
that was my worry with this movie right
that it was going to be like the cg
wouldn't wasn't going to be great
i was like oh it was it was on point but
it was just
you just worry about a movie that's
finished during covet yeah
what the production values gonna be so i
know i feel like
it's gonna be lit yeah i don't know i i
feel like this monster universe about to
be big man like i really do like
they're they're getting really good like
they're definitely doing good i want to
finish uh king's daughter on the mecca
so everyone started the mecca because i
definitely want to i don't know yeah
okay so
um my thoughts on the mecca i thought
they did it really well i thought uh
they had to show that there was nobody
in control from the rip
because usually what happens is they
lose control mid fight
or whatever the same tropes no from the
rip he was
let loose right and he was just tearing
stuff up they showed that
uh the powers that he was using the
energy that was used to power him
was the natural fusion energy from
godzilla
himself you know so they was able to
formulate that synthesize that and then
inject that into him to give him full
strength because anytime he did use it
uh it was uh you know he would power
down because he used it so quickly
the natural energy that we did have i
got to say this
um just to let you know how
weak the skull crawlers were compared to
alpha uh a true alpha uh
kaiju as like godzilla those uh skull
crawlers were weak because when they had
a full-grown
scroll caller come out to fight
mechagodzilla he just grabbed him by the
armstrong yeah
that was it got him part of the yeah
right and kong was in a dual dot
with a full grown adult skull crawler
but
this this is this is again the levels
this is the levels
right there's levels to this and i think
we'll see uh
kong hollow earth next okay but we can
see
kong actually ascend to that king kong
uh name because he still ended it off
with kong
okay you know that that that's that's
true they have not necessarily
called him king kong per se what's the
distinction that yeah i'm sorry
supposedly doesn't have like armor and
stuff like no like
yeah well i was told that he gets armor
like in the in the
in the lore of calling well in the comic
books
what's the determination to make him
king gone what what i'm just saying like
if they made a determination it probably
just success a long
overarching story right then yeah
building him up to be
kong is like you know lara croft because
oh okay the tomb raider okay okay
so this is a soft boot like school me
like they they they're four movies in
now right there
is four movies in now um so i mean yeah
if they want to continue this and they
want to continue that mythos
like you said the hollow earth thing um
i think yeah they can definitely do it
and there's more they could do with
these characters
but and plus he's getting experience
fighting yeah
like godzilla was the the first big boss
he fought
ever did he get it passed and then i'm
going too hard on him
in that sense if this is he here in
rookie mode
yeah he he's just he's training up like
his that's the reason that kept him
alive yeah his first real
scene of a second type of muto was i
mean
um kaiju was uh the snake one that was
flying right
so he didn't uh interact with a flying
uh
kaiju ever and then he you know he he
defeated one but got wrapped up
you know um you say he's learning down
there
oh you know he's he's he's growing
because on on that
island he was king on the island right
yeah so but he almost died to that the
the the skull crawler
that had him until you know the help he
came and stuff like that right but
what the hell but now he has to be able
to hold the fight on his own without any
shenanigans
no chile lays from under the rope you
know none of this stuff none of these
foreign objects in the ring
he got to be able to hold a card by
itself so i think you know kong
hollow earth is where he would get the
name king kong but hold on novar shout
out to
one of our best mods he said i don't
think they could call him king kong for
licensing reasons
oh probably so maybe okay probably so i
mean but probably by that time they sort
that stuff out
okay you know um there's too much money
involved got you yeah you know at this
point in time it's it's
it's a ton of money involved so they
probably wanted to see what this movie
does in a pandemic what this movie does
on his streaming service
and and and this is a a step in the
right direction for
everything because the last specific rim
movie i think it did record numbers in
that
aspect godzilla more interest in
godzilla than ever before
uh you know with netflix shows and
pacific rim having those cartoons
so i say they cultivate the the kong
licensee
uh go into the hollow off or he can have
him fight different mutos there i mean
in hollow earth yeah in the hollow earth
as he
learns his craft because you saw him
being a little bit more agile
he had a larger open she was there at
the end of the movie yeah
shut up over there he says by pharaoh
let me go ahead and post on twitter for
people starting in here
well wait wait we're still ending this
at 2 30.
oh no i thought you meant that i told
you about supposed to get sorry okay
solve nobody gets you on the um
your thoughts on mecca and stuff like
that yeah like i said
to me i i like the fact that they made
him a more agile like if you watch the
old movies
he's just uh literally like a like a
stiff robot with
like he's he's like he's like a war
machine basically like he's war machine
but with a stiff robot
right so the fact that they made him
agile and they made him be able to take
on these two alpha titans
um they needed to do that they didn't do
that and i think that's the benefit to
having these type of movies come out now
in a time where cgi
is so prevalent and good cgi is
prevalent and you can
make these things come to life like like
anything else in the way that we imagine
them when we're young right
when you're young you can get over the
fact that they're men in rubber suits
and whatever
but now that now like you need to be
wild and i think they're doing a great
job of it because they could have
it could have come off cheesy like to me
my thing is i think they need to rethink
the comedy angles in this
not to say that comic relief isn't good
but
in the other movies as serious as they
were tone wise
you did have the little joke thrown in
you did have the character that was kind
of the
the butt of the joke all the time or
whatever um the
the kind of the punchline guy but it was
never to this
extent and i think like for somebody
like you that came in and just watched
this one
certain parts of it will leave a nasty
taste in your mouth to compare
comparison to the other movies right
like if you really into the action you
will love it for its action but i
really i really do think you need the
context of the other movies to see
why they got i've seen them but it's
been so long yeah
and they really do follow kind of one
behind the other so
but i i enjoyed the mechagodzilla i
enjoyed everything they did even you
know with my man taking the l because
the you know
i just did
the good thing is you know i was worried
about a couple things is i i
at least there was some form of
explanation it was still plant armor but
it
it's not like like kong just
miraculously
started like going super saiyan it like
you know at least
everything happened in the movie isn't
some real
possibility it's just there's a lot of
variables that need to happen like and
i'm glad they didn't
do the oh kong's about to beat win or
godzilla's about to win and god
and mechagodzilla shows up out of
nowhere and they look at each other like
okay we got to fight him now
so like no doubt no i mean i jumped in
you got a clear-cut winner
yeah i don't know we wrap it up but yeah
i thought um like overall like the back
of godzilla that was dope because it
gave i think attic mentioned it it gave
kong that that victory that i felt like
needed to to kind of like turn the tide
and then
come together you know what i'm saying
so i like put it this way i like that we
got a conclusion to the fight
right right with a winner so they didn't
play us that way you also always play us
and then you don't get it you know what
i mean so we got that and
then we got to team up you know classic
trope kind of thing you know i thought
he was doing i thought the cg was fire i
like like what you said king
how he was untethered from the rip so i
want to see what he could do
he was roughing godzilla he was dragging
godzilla like when he got when he
grabbed the head
he squeegeed his face against the
buildings and he was doing it yeah
anything godzilla he had an answer for
he was
there was no way godzilla was beating
that like it was like a scorpion tale
too
yeah the tail it was crazy i think
i think one of the biggest issues is
mecca godzilla was designed and
programmed to fight godzilla
you know he was the opposite program to
fight some random kong that's been
that's put under some some random
like dome that like 10 percent of people
knew about
yeah we get it is it especially the acts
that it actually definitely changes they
made that mechagodzilla to withstand
like any elements on earth
right well the axe is not from earth
right because the axe is from
earth earth it is from hollywood
now we know how strong the dorsal fin oh
god
yes like especially when they're charged
up so that's another um
mcguffin um that they can explore you
saw how many axes khan
kong did have his uh
he asked them to spare yeah like there
was enough godzilla that was murdered
by the hands of his people oh but that
place did collapse upon itself
yeah so maybe that's that that that
that source of uh weaponry is might be
gone
yeah yeah we gotta see one axe that he
does have is the one that's left over
i i thought to to end my thoughts on it
i i actually thought the build up
was greater than um
the actual release because i thought oh
the builder but
the film sorry right but again i got to
say this because
this tones like saab room was saying in
the other films was
really serious right and it was
character driven by the
the human elements to it but this was
driven by the animalistic uh nature of
the monsters
and i felt that they depicted each
monster
to their characteristics to their
essence
and they showed more diversity in any
godzilla film that i've ever seen as far
as godzilla goes like
godzilla always had a mode where he can
fight
he had to get dirty with kong he had
down on the ground with kong
yeah and he had to just really pull out
all the stops with kong
to exert his superiority without
actually outright killing him right so
it was like
i'm big brother you're gonna respect
this hustle right now
right you're gonna lay down you're gonna
bend the knee and he's yelling
about to give his clothing all right
there we go
oh yeah that was like i said with the
back of godzilla um it was it was dope i
love that conclusion
listen i'm not i ain't gonna hold you
i'm not really into these type of films
but i will say i understand
why y'all get into the spectacle like
it's it's a spectacle it's boxing it's
like
your man versus this man we want to see
the match up oh but your man got help
if he wouldn't have won here so i get it
now i now i understand why these things
are and for that it's like i i'm not
going to take it as serious as i would
say because i i came into some
like solve i was expecting this you know
this theatrical
thing and i'm like no this is rock'em
sock of robots yeah
yeah just get out get out there and mix
it up but otherwise i did it i did enjoy
that aspect of it
and looking to see if they continue you
know the mythos let's get the super
chats to get out of here so
so attica do you know what is funny
though i'll say this real quick because
how is it that whoever's making these
monster movies
they're building uh they're they're
taking the time to build a better
universe and dc does
agreed king next movie kong should be
ascending to his throne
and we'll see if it happens then we have
crazy horse five dollars to protect
in the 1962 crossover kong was the first
and only monster to beat godzilla
hmm yeah okay uh then we got best eyes
fine it's five dollars to attack king
once again if it wasn't for the human
saving kong mecca godzilla damn near
killed him
with his tail the story would have been
all over
this island could have would have it
ain't happening
he ride it he ride it for his big
respect i respect that
i'm not going to confirm or deny that
that footage is on the cutting room
floor
then we got fozzie five dollars kong
about to turn into a hammer brother
we all cut up i believe so yeah we're
gonna go back
down so look man locked down let's see
who we got yeah so good for
everybody in the realm you know what i'm
saying to pull it up for this r and r
because obviously we would have
a real quick let's talk for two minutes
i want people in the chat to who you
think we're having on
yeah i want to see a couple guests now
you could obviously go ahead and start
doing it
but i want to see people's thoughts on
who they think we're having on
before they know who we're having
hustler [ __ ] he said what's up
pm two five p.m eastern eastern standard
time on tuesday
nano said major nelson okay okay
phil spence today westfield dominance
first person
first person to say you get getting a
code sadly
that's a good choice yeah we want to
serve will be nice
yo
yeah i'm running well if
look hold up real quick if it is if it
does show up in the chat
do not say anything because i want okay
i want to be able to say
you know got that
got that right mm-hmm dude okay okay
a lot of good choices but look like i
said we did this jace ryan we already
had jason ronald and jason
will be back in the rum though shout out
to that reggie reggie
raymond
but right now he's in rehab fixing his
broken ego
but look like i said we we did a special
episode uh shout out to king again for
still doing this one because obviously
our special guests could not
do this one but it's tuesday 5 p.m
eastern
very special in the realm the legendary
from last stand media's own
colin moriarty will be in the realm
tuesday 5 p.m eastern big show
a lot of stuff to talk about obviously
everyone's waiting for the king they
want his bars on that
but we are going to deep dive we're
going to talk about some playstation
we're going to talk about everything
that y'all want to talk about man so
tune in
special edition it is going to be lit
and again thank you all for pulling up
today
because y'all knew we still we was going
to do our official show which i still
pulled up
for the special edition r and r so
that's what i got let's do our outros
real quick
add it where can i find people what you
got going on sir
the uk you can follow me on twitter lord
addict iop definitely go there and
follow me on twitter i'm trying to hit
that three thousand uh followers
i'm like six hundred or six thousand
away so you know we
we we doing the future we're gonna where
we're doing
huh he said you're six thousand away
from three thousand
it's like it's not it's negatives
right now i'm sitting at 24. so i'm like
600
i was joking oh okay but um all right so
you know first off uh
king and me will be streaming always out
again tomorrow
uh wait a way out no yeah no no no no no
no no it takes two yeah
um i got some stuff to do tomorrow but
that's at nine
you know a.m in the morning then i got
it is that good
um probably a little bit later four
people probably yeah probably like four
p.m
all right so 4 p.m we're going to do it
uh you know keep in mind
that's twitter we'll tell you yeah i i
am bringing addict's show to this
channel
so keep looking up for stuff like that
absolutely i was
because of everything going on i'll
probably delay mine from tomorrow to
next week
and you know it's like i said we're
going to have calling on tuesday
now obviously this is a really good time
to have colin to have his
perspective on some of the stuff
happening on playstation right now
so um you know definitely look out for
that man it's gonna it's gonna be show
man it's gonna be a show
absolutely lord solve where can i find
people find you what you got going on
sir
nothing man just chilling you got a few
more days left to vacation and then it's
back to work
but uh excited for tuesday uh always
been a fan of colin's work so to have
him in the realm is gonna be very fun
very interesting to have this man on
his perspective is he has a very cool
perspective on the games industry and
he's been around for a long time
so especially since we don't get
playstation-centric people
on it is going to be a it's a great time
to have somebody like him on and talk
about
what the hell is going on over there
absolutely absolutely and
of course the king pull it up getting
the lords together
we gave him his achievement early you
know we're gonna find people find you
what you got going on and thank you
again
for making us do and bring back the r
this is this this is
this is g not changing the time was gene
was genius yeah it was it was fun it was
a fun thing um
our bodies already acclimated to it we
never missed we always hit our target
we wanted to give you something light
fun and a little bit different you know
and also talk about our current events
because we all
you know live in a society anyway um
if you don't know what i'm talking about
but um this is this was fun and and to
see the turnout for the people that was
here
also like follow and subscribe let's get
those uh those likes up so let's share
this stuff out
um remember it was a spoiler castle i'm
sorry if you walked into the fight
please read before you walk in the room
and and we will be doing one of these on
um
on mortal kombat yes yeah definitely on
the 23rd
so we're going to give you a couple of
days to get that but we're going to get
that working
yeah you're going to get this but this
this is fun i i do
appreciate all you guys for coming out
follow me on twitter king david otw
where i'm out here setting fire to the
internet
shout out to that video though with it
they were waiting for you in droves with
that news drop
yo the crazy thing is the king no plato
baseball he don't play
he just you know he's being messy you
know he'd be a messy
yo i'm i'm gonna ask the internet for
one thing
and i'm i want us to rock i want
i want game pass and i want us to
rock the the web i want us to crash that
game that day
come out i want all 25
million subscribers to
to download that game and to boot it up
and and just just crash show the numbers
show the metrics show how strong we are
let us get god of war spiderman
we're going to do more you know stuff
like this
uh we're still working on the somatics
but you know
we we do stuff like you know we we had
over 200 people showed up like you guys
are you got you guys really mess with us
man
like you really do this godzilla versus
king kong like
obviously like it's not gaming related
and a lot of the times when
when you do content like this that's not
what the [ __ ] what the actual channel is
about like that the numbers are
are greatly half but it wasn't like that
man so i definitely
appreciate that uh we will see you guys
tuesday
at 5 00 p.m eastern no doubt addicts not
let me talk again but i'm going to get
my bars off anyway
yeah oh and i agree with him bro he's
right he's right he's actually right
because at the end of the day
they didn't you know got people didn't
have to be here and guys still rock with
us to the end
shout out to the raiden blade the two
possible chat okay king compliant
that's right you go with the compliance
thing you know what i'm saying but we
got that
but um yeah like i said at the end of
the day um salute to the realm for
pulling up
and um like i said we're super excited
about tuesday
it's gonna be lit oh man we got a lot
more fun things planned the next two
months y'all y'all
not ready iov we're gonna do some stuff
a lot more content that's all i got
anybody else we are good nope all right
we're good so we catch up tuesday 5 p.m
eastern
colin moriarty i already know what it is
peace
[Music]
you